Allah Allah ben
ama annem üç gün aynı çorbaya da önümüze
koyduğu zaman
bu burun kıvırdı kanalımda derdi ki
sokağa bakın
bu anam niye böyle diyor derdim sonra 16
yaşında sokağa bakmayı öğrendim Sokağı
anladım
Ben 17 yaşında da cezaevine yaptın Evet
hayat hikayesi orada başladı Altı
evlerinde öğrendiğim tiyatroyu kendi
kendime Hücremde yapmaya başladım
kendime bir dünya kurdum o dünyanın
içinde hayatı hikayemi yazmaya başladım
Onun için diyorum ki hayallerinizi
hiçbir zaman durdurmayın hangi yaşta
olursanız olun hayallere devam Kendi
hikayeni kendin yaz başkası dikkate
Etmesin Seni Evet kendi Hücremde iki
metrekarelik dünyada bir dünya kurdum
kendime ve çiçek tarlaların vardı
bu ekmeğin vardı göremediğim Kuşlar
vardı Bana dışarıdan haber getirenler
parmaklıkları bir ağaç gibi gördüm ve
yaprakları vardı ve güneşin ışınları o
yaprakları arasında gönlümü açardı
o Ziyaretçim yoktu çünkü annem beni
almaya da okuyor biliyordu
bu ve Ziyaretçim hiç gelmedi bir gün bir
ziyarete çıktım dedim ki Nasıl oluyor
ziyaret çıkarttılar olacağını larda
bu işte anne ile baba arasında ve yavru
arasında bir tane cam vardı İki tane de
kümes teli dediğimiz telden güç
yaşındaydı ziyaretçi çocuk babasına Çok
dik baktı böyle bir vakti ki babasına
ba ba ba Dik Dur dedik
ve babası
o eli kendi baldırına götürdü
Evet şimdi kalktı kendine görüyordum
öyle bir çimdik attı ki dedi ki bir daha
buraya gelme
Ben seni sevmiyorum dedi
bu ve akşam döndüğümüzde eşofmanını
çıkarttı baldırından et koparmıştı bu
evladım onu söylerken İşte o gün dedim
ki eğer bir gün çıkarsam buradan Çünkü
26 kişilik dosya yedik biz altı tane 7am
vardı İçimizden 20 tane de baba
olamayacak adam gördüğümüz şeylerden 19
yaşında baba olamayacağımı anladım
da değişme söyledim benden evlat gelmez
sana diye O da dışarıda bir sürü evlat
var dedi onları hepsi bizim
bu Eyvallah Ah evet dedim ki döneceğim
bu çocuklar için döneceğim dedim 81
yılında döndüm olacağım Lara tekrar Ben
Sinop cezaevinden çıkmıştım
bir bir buçuk saat karşı Kaldırıma
geçirmiştim Sinop'ta her şey çok
değişmişti yeni yılda 81 yılında gittim
tiyatro yapmaya
bir tiyatro yaparken mahkumlu işçi
oluyorsun sana dertlerini anlatıyorlar o
zamanlar yani 70'li 80'li dönemlerde
kader mahkumları vardı şimdi bana göre
Kader Mahkumu içerdekilerin dışarıda
bıraktığı yavrular Yani içerdekiler pek
bana Kader mahkumuyuz demesinler ama
dışarıda bayrakları kadınları çocukları
esas kaderi çeker ver Evet o zaman ve
evlada yaklaştım
Ben 45 yaşında şimdi
Ben dedim Seni ben okuldayım izin aldık
aileden
çok değişik a göndermeye
ve ekonomik destek yapmaya çalıştık
Tiyatroları aldığım parayla Yeşim'in
maaşıyla
daha sonra baktıkları gidenler çocuklara
ulaşmıyor bu sefer tutmaya başladık Ve
ailemiz çoğalmaya başladı
bu içinden iki tane savcı bir tane
Avukat çıktı çocuklarımızın Yani şunu
demeye çalışıyorum Yani aslında olarak
ben iyilik yapmıyorum ben kendime yemek
yapıyorum Çünkü ben o yoksullukları çok
çektim üç yıl yetimhanede ezik
bu işte cumartesi anneme giderdim
Ben annemi elim ayağıma dirseklerimi bak
Ardahan'ı kavga etti mi diye
daha sonra the Dirty çocukları çağırdı
derdi bir fıstık çalardı bütün sokak
bizim kapıda Ya annem çıkığından çıkarır
25 kuruş herkese 25'er kuruş verildi
Hadi bakkala gidin derdi Siz Gazoz için
şimdi belki gazozlu pek bilmiyorsunuz
ama o zaman sadece gazoz vardı o tozu
dumana katarak bakkala giderdik Bakkal
amca Bakalım amca Bakalım cavak al amca
bizi çok severdi sonra abilerden birine
sordum niye Bakkal Bizi çok seviyor Hani
lokum bisküvi veriyor bize bize dedi ki
abilerden biri Onun dediği hiç çocuğu
yok
ya ondan sizi çok seviyor dedi de onun
için dışarıdaki dışarıdaki çocuklar var
ya hani o tinerci dediğin gördüğün zaman
Yolları değiştirdiğin o evlatlar var ya
Aslında onlar sana hediye ben derim cap
o cezaevlerinde şu an 725 tane evlat
yatıyor anneleriyle İşte o çocuklar bir
gün Sokak çocuklarıyla Sokak Çocukları
senin evinde ki çocukla da aynı parkta
aynı salıncağa bindikleri gün bu ülkede
barışı yakalarız Biz Evet Sağolun yani
Çocuklara dokunmayı bilelim o sokak
çocuğu dediği not enerji dediğin çocuğa
bir gün Merhaba de uzaktan herkes gün
biraz yaklaş Merhaba de 3. günü o sana
diyecek Merhaba bugün omzuna dokundu
sadece geç git beraber bir şey yiyorsan
mesela al bir tane simit simiti paylaş
olma Onun gözünün önünde ertesi gün o
sana yaklaşacak
bu ve giderek onu almaya başlayacaksın
Sen kendi çocuğuna kadar çok seviyorsan
onu da sevmek zorundasın çünkü senin
çocuğun sokağa çıktığı zaman onunla
muhatap olacak Onun için sen ona değil
Kendine iyilik yapıyorsun Ben de öyle 66
yaşındayım ama hala kendime iyilik
yapıyorum niye iyilik yapıyorum çünkü
eksiklerim vardı Baba'yı görmemişti
güveneceğim İz daha yoktu cezaevi
filmleri ne bakın hep duvara Yaslanır
insanlar Çünkü verecekleri tek yer orası
ama kadın kadın var ya kadın işten büyük
duvar Eğer ben kadınıma içmeyi Aslan mı
Saydım bu kadar evladına sahip Olamazdım
Zaten onun için Hint adını
en sevdiğin kadar sevmez seveceksin Eve
gittiğin zaman Elinizi yüzünüzü
yıkarsanız makyajları yapmak için aynaya
bakarsın aynaya kendini sevdiğin için
bak bir kere Bak sen ne güzelsin desen
ne iyisin de kendinden bir kesme al
sokağa öyle çık barışık olursun Yağmur
da olsa Card olsa barışık görürsün
deneyin hayallerinizi durdurmayın Sevda
ile başka bir çocuklarıma bir adet
yaptık ki
Ne yaparlar Bunlar işte Kızlar bir odada
erkekler bir adada küçükler yani sıfır
yaşlı altı yaş arasındaki evlatlar
cezaevinden Aldıklarım Ama sabah
kalktıklarında ellerini yüzlerini
yıkarlar birbirine sarılırlar Ondan
sonra gelip sofraya otururlar Çünkü gece
yatarken birbirini incitmiş olabilirler
yıllar geçti bir tanesi Avukat oldu bir
tanesi savcı
o gün WhatsApp çağırdı beni İzmir'den
var ya dedi ne biçim çocuk
yetiştirmişsin şimdi Savcı uyarmış
WhatsApp acı Sen ne yapıyorsun şöyle
duruşmadan çıkıp demiş Avukatta
sarılıyorsun falan demiş yakışıyor mu
yar imiş o benim kardeşim Onun için
insanı seven ilk önce kendini sev
kendine ilk önce kendini seveceksin
sonra başkasını Sev Ben İlk önce kendimi
seviyorum Turgay diyorum adam ol adam
hala adam oluyorum Ala Çünkü bu ülkenin
adamları ihtiyacı var Sizin gibi değerli
annelere kadınlara ihtiyacı var en küçük
kızıma ben annem kadar saygı duyuyorum
Çünkü bir anne adayı o Çocuk doğurur
doğurmaz o Yüreğiniz var ya başka bir
şey çay çayı çok severim hep bardaktan
içelim
Ama sizler de böyle koşulu mudur Çünkü
küçük çayı o bardağın 6 var ya 6 the 6
nov ucuna koyduğun zaman o sıcaklığı ana
sıcaklığı dırr Eğer Anadolu uzaksan o
sıcaklığı anlayamazsın İşte o sıcaklığı
verir onun için hep görürsünüz görselde
o çayları öyle içilir bir tabaklama
bakla olmaz o iş Evet yani duygusal hız
maalesef Çünkü duyduğumuz bizi adam
ediyor bu Mesleğimi ben kullanıyorum
tiyatroyu kullanıyorum Eğer tiyatro
olmasaydı cezaevlerine o kadar rahat
girip de oyunlar oynayıp o insanımızla
beraber olamam Ha şu da var İçerdeki
insan dışarıdaki insana acılar vermiş
geldi yani halk arasında vardır iki
ucunu pislik de
bu işte öyle bir dünya içerideki Benim
ülkemin insanı diye saygı duyuyorum
dışarıda acı çeken acımdan dolayı ona
saygı duyuyorum işte iki tarafın
barışması önemli barışmak Sevda ile olur
sevgiyle olur düşünün bakın birbirinizi
tanımıyorsunuz ama aynı yerde
oturuyorsunuz otururken Merhaba
demediniz belki birbirinize ama giderken
Hadi iyi akşamlar değilseniz bu kadar
kitle merhaba demiş olacak ülkenin buna
ihtiyacı vardı Ben sevdim ve hala
konuşması yapmaya gelmedim sadece
duygularımı paylaşmak istedim İçinizde
10 tane evladım var şu an oturan onları
dedi ki
var ama sakın duygusallaşma olmuyor ki
bu olmuyor yani a Eyvallah Ah Yani bu
ülkede Herkes birbirine layık olması
gerekiyor Bizim de strobus şu
Çocuklarımın da onu öğretmeye
çalışıyorum ben hep yatılı kaldım yatılı
okudum yetiştirme yurdu cezaevi
konservatuvar askerlik yani tanımadığım
adamların vergileri benim maaşım oldu
benim kursam dan çocuğumun kursağından
geçiyor onun için bu ülkede herkes
birbiriyle merhabalaşma lı herkesin
birbirine karşı sorunu var Sevdası var
minneti var yaradandan sonra benim
ülkemin insanına benim milletim vardır
İyi ki varsınız diyorum
Çok teşekkür ederim